[Music]
you know I wake up every morning my
first thought is what part of me is not
working today and we have passengers on
boat slowly sinking your boat is slow
I'm like when the Titanic was pointing
up so how's your love life you're still
seeing uh what's-her-name Triscuit
Tristan and no oh that's too bad she was
kind of cute
well we know much to talk about you know
she was half my age half your age is
still an old woman like you know I mean
it was a mess never visitor oh sandy hey
kiddo
listen I know I've gone wide you look at
the Norman me yeah you're his best
friend right I don't know am i no no
don't argue with her you got it
[Music]
listen to me we're all scared because
it's a scary [ __ ] world but we get
through it because we're not alone me
you dumb [ __ ] come I love me you're just
depressed it'll pass it'll pass
my job doesn't fulfill me anymore and I
just put my 45 year old daughter in
rehab just keep going you know you're
not the only one here with problems Oh
what are your problems you're seeing
this nice Lisa woman I mean are you
crazy about me you amuse me I'll take it
do you have a thriving business the
wonderful loving daughter Rainey Ben
bathroom again
what's wrong nothing's wrong I think
something's going on with this prostate
[Music]
it hurts to be human it hurts like hell
and all the exploring in the world
doesn't make that hurt go away because
being human and being hurt or the same
damn thing how was your day I had a
strange little man stick his finger up
my ass you complete me I envy you
[Music]
you